look all i'm trying to say is
that you are who you are
find what gives you joy
and you do that thing
no apologies whatever it is
that brings you pleasure in this world
hey guys pete here this is my breakdown
for dexter new blood episode 8. we had a
tense chase some big developments in the
story and we're beginning to see the
setup for the ending starting to take
shape it was one of those situations
where you could piece together that
there was going to be a convergence of
these characters at the cabin i talked
about that in my teaser breakdown
preview for this episode but you still
couldn't say how that might play out and
where things would be left at the end
and we will get into all of that after a
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched episode 8 of dexter new blood
yet this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
unfair game opens with dexter knocked
out in the back of belrick's truck where
he has a dream about the high school
kids coming to the cabin after harrison
who absolutely beats them down and
ultimately kills them he comes in at the
end to see him smiling with blood on his
face and then he wakes up he realizes
where he's at and that he can't get out
of his zip ties kurt calls elric to
check in he tells his boss that he has
dexter and asks if he's handling his son
we see kurt wearing that same i don't
know what you would call it lab clothing
he was wearing before when we saw him
trying to fix chloe's face and he says
that he's handling everything dexter
realizes that harrison is in trouble and
he's able to use the zip ties to hook
elric's mouth and get him to crash the
truck off the road he's thrown through
the window as it hits a telephone pole
and besides the obvious injuries from
that he's well enough to move he gets
himself loose and then sees albrecht
coming after him with a rifle which he
uses to shoot him in the leg as he's
running into the woods he lets us know
that his plan is to lose the guy get
back to his truck and find his son the
chase goes on for most of the episode
with scenes cut in between the other
stories we see deb show up at different
times to aiden his beating himself up
about this all being his fault we catch
up with harrison who's walking around
town he's still upset from when dexter
intervened when he was slashing at the
other school's wrestlers and eventually
kurt calls him and he uses that he got
in a fight with dexter as a way for them
to get together he tells him he'll come
pick him up and adds i've got a surprise
for you the surprise is that he's taking
him to the high school saying that they
haven't changed the lock since he was
matt's wrestling coach so he can walk
right in they talk about what a good
athlete his son was and how their
relationship isn't that great saying
they never communicated well and
emphasizing not like you and me they
used the pitching machine in the batting
cages kurt was obviously a good ball
player and he learns that harrison never
played so he shows him how he starts
hitting the ball and then kurt says it's
getting too easy so he makes an
adjustment to the machine he says let's
try a curveball and it ends up hitting
him right in his side harrison shakes it
off he gets right back in there they
continue to hit him and things change
where harrison's asking him to keep
going while he's thinking of the painful
moments he's experienced with his father
since arriving in iron lake and it's
like he's punishing himself at the end
kurt tells him he's one tough kid and
asks him if he's ever eaten venison
while telling him he thinks he sees some
quality scotch in his future they leave
the school and they head towards the
cabin
in her office angela is looking at
batista's instagram she's looking at a
bowling picture with dexter and i think
it's kind of funny that he's wearing a
hat in his profile picture and it just
shows that she is lingering on the idea
of who her boyfriend is and perhaps what
this co-worker of his might be able to
tell her about him logan comes in and
she quickly closes the tab and as
they're talking he brings up that dexter
nearly killed the drug dealer after
harrison od'd since she was gone this is
all news to her and she decides to go to
the crystalline to ask the drug dealer
miles about what happened when dexter
assaulted him he tells her the truth
about how it actually happened she's
surprised that he asked about drugs to
lure him outside he didn't come straight
in and start a confrontation and that he
didn't start throwing punches until
after the cop showed up he also tells
her about getting poked in the neck with
the needle and she takes a picture of
the injection site
she comes back to the station after
talking to miles and asks logan about
the opioid bust when he says that the
guy od'd about an hour before they
served the search warrant she tries to
work out a logical reason for that
happening maybe miles called him and
tipped him off or something like that
but logan tells her it would have been
impossible because he was still in
custody when she hears that dexter was
there too but only for an hour she
starts thinking that he might have been
involved there as well she goes to check
on the body and the coroner says there's
nothing to suggest that this death is
anything other than an accidental
overdose but he does mention that jasper
had ketamine in his system too that
prompts her to want to check one more
thing and she finds an injection site on
his neck and takes another picture
before she leaves
dexter comes across an empty summer camp
and leaves a blood trail so elric can
follow him inside
there he finds a knife and he waits his
plan works and elric does come in dexter
pounces on him by jumping through a
mirror and when he has him on the ground
he asks where kurt has harrison finding
out that he was supposed to bring dexter
to his cabin so that's probably where
they are eric says he was only doing his
job it was nothing personal and as
dexter stabs him in the heart to take
his life he says when you're talking
about my son there's nothing more
personal than that he takes elric's coat
and hat and covers the body with a tarp
and then sees a text from kurt on his
phone he uses his face to unlock it one
more time before he leaves sending a
message so that kurt won't figure out
something's wrong at the cabin curt
introduces harrison to single malt
scotch he tells him that he needs to
stop punishing himself he says you gotta
find what gives you joy and do that
thing at the same time dex is racing to
the cabin in elric's truck wondering if
he should try to warn harrison he goes
back and forth with deb for a while and
eventually decides to send him a text
which harrison sees but he doesn't
answer and then turns his phone on
airplane mode they're talking they're
eating and drinking together kurt
appears to be bonding with him and
definitely he's manipulating him into
thinking he's this great guy and here is
this father figure type relationship
he's been longing for when asked about
the arrest he tells him that his father
murdered a teenage girl and says that
sometimes a kid ends up suffering for
the choices of his father most of this
doesn't matter considering how things
turn out but we do get to hear harrison
say out loud what he truly wants from
his father he came there wanting answers
but realized he wanted a real connection
with his dad he fears that they're too
different and that dexter is always
holding something back which of course
we know what that is and why he's doing
that he's frantically driving and trying
to get a hold of him the whole time
after kurt tells him everything that he
wants to hear he looks at his watch and
says he has something he has to take
care of while he's out of the room
harrison does see that dex has been
calling and then kirk comes back out in
his full gear saying that he wished it
could have worked out differently but i
don't have a choice son sins of the
father it's a [ __ ] up world out there
he tells him to get up and get out
harrison is frantic trying to figure out
what he did if he did something wrong
saying he didn't mean it and he just
keeps repeating he doesn't know what he
did out front kurt turns on the laser
scope and tells him to run and then the
truck starts to approach at first he
thinks it's elric so he wants him to
hurry up and get dexter outside so he'll
see the death of his son but as it keeps
coming for him he realizes elric isn't
driving and he starts shooting in that
direction in order not to get hit he has
to dive out of the way and then he runs
off as harrison and dexter are reunited
his gun was tossed aside so he can't
shoot either one of them and he sort of
disappears in that one minute he's
running in the field they see him there
and they focus to check on each other to
make sure they're all right and when
they look again they don't see kurt
anymore this prompts them to make the
decision to get back into the truck and
get out of there
as they're driving away harrison is
obviously freaked out about what's going
on he doesn't know how dexter ended up
there does he know more about what's
going on here and dex just says there's
so much i need to tell you i should have
way before it got to this you need to
know he tells him he never has to feel
alone with his dark thoughts and you see
him pause after dark like he was
thinking of a different word to use than
passenger because obviously harrison
wouldn't understand that term you were
probably drawn to kurt because you
thought he understood you but i was born
in blood just like you i had the same
violent urges at your age i didn't know
how to deal with them but my dad taught
me a code a way to channel those urges
i'm gonna tell you everything harrison
jumps over to the driver's side to hug
him and dex thinks this is all i had to
do this is all he ever wanted maybe if
i'm being honest maybe this is all i
ever wanted too the episode ends there
but we did have one more scene with
angela at home who was looking through
jasper and miles files and thinking
about ketamine she had google open she
was looking at search results for dexter
morgan miami homicide she changes the
search term to ketamine miami homicide
and gets a result about the bay harbor
butcher it mentions dokes being a member
of miami homicide and says that his
victims were rendered unconscious with
ketamine injected in their neck so based
on what's shown here you can understand
how she got to that information
and it's another episode that continued
to stoke the build up maybe it's a
slight step down from the last couple
but still one of the stronger episodes
it's like you can finally take a breath
now that dexter is coming clean to
harrison who is at a place where he's
ready to receive this information
they've been building this up for so
long and you really never knew whether
it was gonna happen or not so it's good
to see that it did the characters can
move on it answers harrison's questions
with the added bonus of having a very
plausible explanation for why it hadn't
happened up until this point the ticking
clock nature of this episode means that
not a lot of time has passed if you
think about the end of episode 7 this
all happened in that same day there's
quite a few loose ends here dexter left
a dead body with a lot of evidence that
ties him to the murder in elric at the
summer camp angela sort of shifted focus
going down a rabbit hole for the day but
iris's body being discovered is still
fresh in her mind and now they have the
christmas holiday coming up so it'll be
interesting to see how the next two
episodes play out time wise he'll have
to teach harrison the code or introduce
him to that while trying to stay ahead
of kurt and ultimately take him out but
i'll speculate about all of that in my
next video there's still a lot that we
don't understand about why kurt does
what he does though i went in thinking
that if all of these three characters
came together at the cabin that not all
of them would leave alive but here we
are what was kurt talking about when he
said i wish it could have worked out
differently on the one hand it seemed
like he was connecting with harrison
which was completely unnecessary for
killing him out back as he ran away i
guess part of that was because he wanted
dexter to be there he was waiting for
elric to get there but even so what he
said doesn't make it sound like the
motivation was purely for revenge he
chose harrison this time because of that
but his compulsion to kill goes deeper
trying to find a replacement for chloe
after he was forced to shoot her in the
face taking the risk of going after
molly none of that was about revenge or
dexter the way he's acted has shown us
that he has some kind of other motive
that hasn't been revealed dexter and
kurt both know that it's killer be
killed now there's no other course this
could take that doesn't end with one of
them dead dexter killed matt kurt tried
to kill harrison and now at the end of
the episode they're both operating in
the same small town that feels like it's
not big enough for the both of them
anymore as we get closer to the ending
it does feel like they're going to go
the route that i talked about in my
house should it end video with angela
closing in the likely scenarios where
dexter walks away from this alive or
free are just diminishing by the minute
and it's fitting that she's the one who
is starting to unravel the case because
you can assume that who she was is part
of the reason why he's with her he
wanted to be close to law enforcement
even in his being abstinent in the
lead-up to new blood he was still
keeping his options open otherwise why
would a person who's hiding out under an
assumed name trying to run away from
their past choose to get into a
relationship with a cop sure some luck
had to go away but i think it's fitting
that it will ultimately feel like it
comes from this choice he made when
things fall apart the ketamine thing is
a little annoying since most people who
paid attention know that he used
something called m99 in the original
series it's not really important that he
changed what he used i mean he's going
to use what he has available to him but
her making the connection based on that
sort of made me scratch my head of like
why would they do that and i guess there
may still be an explanation but i mean
it's probably just one of those things
like harrison's age that doesn't mesh
exactly with the original and you have
to decide whether you're willing to
accept that or not i think more
interestingly that the ending of this
episode brought up the truth at the
center of the dexter character and it
does a lot to set up a satisfying ending
when he's thinking about the effect that
telling the truth has had on harrison he
says maybe if i'm being honest maybe
this is all i ever wanted too it's a
revelation for him in that moment with
his son but as viewers we already know
that's what he's been searching for it
came out in different ways throughout
the series but it's pretty plain in the
relationships he had with significant
others deep down he's always just wanted
someone to see him as he was and accept
him that way now his son can do that and
it's sort of an equal exchange in that
harrison also gets the father figure and
understanding he's always wanted so
however it goes wrong from here they'll
already have had that and i think that's
a good place to leave things for now let
me know in the comments what you thought
about this episode how you're feeling as
we're getting closer to the ending of
the series what you think is going to
happen in the next two episodes and what
you're hoping to see please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
i'll have my preview and theories video
out in a couple of days so check back
for that and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon